♪ ♪
>> John: IT'S BEEN FIVE YEARS
SINCE THE WHITE SMOKE AT THE
SISTINE CHAPEL INDICATED A NEW
POPE HAD BEEN NAMED.
TONIGHT BRET BAIER TALKS WITH
CARDINAL DONALD WUERL.
>> THANKS, JOHN.
TOMORROW IS THE FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF POPE FRANCIS'
ELECTION.
TO TALK ABOUT THAT, JOINING ME
NOW CARDINAL DONALD WUERL,
ARCHBISHOP OF WASHINGTON, AND TO
WEIGH IN ON THE LAST FIVE YEARS
OF THE PAPACY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> YOU ARE WELCOME.
IT'S A GREAT JOY TO BE BACK TO
BE WITH YOU.
AND TO THINK, CELEBRATING THE
FIFTH ANNIVERSARY OF
POPE FRANCIS.
I THINK THE IMPACT OF
POPE FRANCIS IS PEOPLE SEE IN
HIM, HE BEARS WITNESS WITH HIS
LIFE, NOT JUST HIS WORDS.
HIS WHOLE IMPACT, AS I SEE IT,
IS HE'S OPENED UP THE CHURCH IN
NO WAY THAT PEOPLE FEEL THEY ARE
MUCH MORE WELCOME.
HE SAYS TO THEM, THERE IS SPACE
FOR ALL OF US HERE IN THIS
CHURCH.
>> I HAVE SEEN THE MAP OF HIS
TRAVEL.
IT'S QUITE SOMETHING.
IT'S EXTENSIVE.
>> IT IS.
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED, HE SAID I
DON'T THINK I WILL BE MOVING
AROUND AS MUCH AS PREVIOUS
POPES.
THAT TURNED OUT NOT TO BE TRUE
AT ALL.
FOR AS OLD AS HE IS, HE
CONTINUES TO CARRY OUT THE
SCHEDULE OF SOMEONE 20 YEARS
YOUNGER.
HE'S HAVING AN IMPACT EVERYWHERE
HE GOES.
>> Bret: HE MET WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP REMARKED ON THE
CONVERSATION THEY HAD.
THEY ARE CONSERVATIVES I GUESS
YOU WOULD SAY IN THE U.S. WHO
ARE SKEPTICAL OF SOME OF THE
POLITICS PERHAPS, HOW HE
EXPRESSES THE IDEOLOGY
SOMETIMES.
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT FOR
YOUR CONGREGATIONS HERE?
TALKING ABOUT IDEOLOGY AND
POLITICS WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PULP.
>> ONE OF THE WONDERFUL THINGS
ABOUT POPE FRANCIS IS HE DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE INHIBITED BY
CATEGORIES, BY LABELING.
HE SAYS WHAT HE THINKS ON A
PARTICULAR TOPIC, AND HE SAYS IT
NOT IN POLITICAL TERMS AND NOT
IN IDEOLOGICAL TERMS.
YOU ARE RIGHT, THOSE ARE --
THERE ARE THOSE WHO WOULD TRY TO
PUT IT IN ONE OF THOSE
CATEGORIES.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
ATTRACTIVE THINGS ABOUT
POPE FRANCIS.
PEOPLE REALIZE HE'S JUST
SPEAKING FROM HIS HEART.
IT'S NOT FROM SOME PRECONCEIVED